egal ich unterstützt du dir jetzt ein
bisschen mit mit worten ich liebe dieses
mal leider passieren
hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge minecraft triple viele leute haben
ihr unter die letzte folge geschrieben
dass sie das endlich mal wieder sehen
wollte da hab ich mir gedacht ich nehme
es mal wieder aus an alle die minecraft
triple eventuell noch nicht kennen
beziehungsweise irgendwie neu auf meinem
kanal sind was ich eigentlich nicht
denke weil die serie noch relativ neu
ist und noch nicht so ein alter knacker
der nicht mal richtig aufstehen
hier geht's auf jeden fall darum dass
ich drei spiele spiele drei mini games
und zwar minecraft bedways micros super
smash mops und minecraft heyden coo und
das werde ich jetzt einfach mal machen
das heißt ich zocke gerade einfach etwas
hab jetzt kann ich wir sind schon fast
haben was macht die denn da hinten alter
geht die ist in welchem team bin ich
eigentlich in roth ich habe wieso habe
ich dann noch 20 spieler junge diana
einfach drei eigentlich hatten wir auch
aber anfang mal 3 dann hole ich mir mal
eben noch einen schwer mich macht es
auch mal eben ihren schweren an die hier
nimm das schwert
ich möchte hier eine freude
du nimmst jetzt ist es wenn ich dich
kriege nimm was hat die auf ihrem rücken
raub nimmt das jetzt mit da schlägt das
kann nicht sein
du nimmst jetzt das schwert ich habs
jetzt und da geht es auf jetzt geht's
erst mal ich glaube
ja ja ja ja
der ist da hinten hat schon den namen
wieder am start aber das juckt es
natürlich nicht weil wir gehen natürlich
locker geschmeidig einfach so
erschrocken dass da doch 22 das ist
einfach mal richtiges berghausen glück
ich habe die runde genau angefangen als
es losging und ich war einfach am anfang
noch zu dritt warten steht es noch im
chat dass irgendeiner jemanden links
verlassen junge spiel startet in einer
sekunde robert das spiel verlassen junge
was soll das alter der fall es einfach
das spiel und lässt uns hier alleine
egal ich unterstützte die jetzt ein
bisschen mit worten ich liebe dieses
michael trip leider passieren ich muss
ein bisschen leiser sein ich bin ganz
klein also ich habe zwei bier getrunken
das ist jetzt das merkt man eigentlich
gar nicht mehr aber ich muss mal
bisschen leiser sein ich hatte ganz
einfach nur mega bock auf minecraft
triple und die letzte folge ist auch
schon ein bisschen länger her aber ich
habe jetzt gibt gold krieg natürlich gar
nichts ist hier natürlich wieder mal
eine runde auf weil es so viele leute
geschrieben im jahr das ist pizza de
reisen schwert am start gehabt und was
geht denn jetzt ab hier alter der pläne
freunde nicht mitgerechnet
auch der crafter erst zwei bier
getrunken
ich bin da schon so ein bisschen hat man
das nicht abgehen abgehärtet so ein
bisschen ein zwei bier ne danke danke
spitze
ich bin wieder da
wieder richtig knapp alter wir müssen
das nur irgendwie über die zeit bringen
ich schreibe mir toll das ist derzeit
das ist englisch und heißt bist du
zufrieden mit mohn entschieden das habe
ich bei fifa ultimate team immer
geschrieben wenn ich nur einen punkt
noch brauchte für die meisterschaft und
dann habe ich halt einfach kein boxer
nicht abgebauten ich glaube sei wohl
nicht der krieg nicht abgebaut
der kriegt sich abgebaut der krieg war
das sein er hilft dir du legst dich
aufgebot
guck mal da ist das ein cooles kopf
sitzen draußen am stadion
okay wir müssen das irgendwie über die
zeit bringen ich habe da aber glaube ich
wo ein camp ja eigentlich schon eine
ganz gute taktik am start und zwar jetzt
erst mal wird das bett ein bisschen
eingebaut darum kommt hier immer so eine
animation ist er ich habe gerade das ist
die rote von uns aber was ist denn wieso
her ich verstehe dass ich wie so was ein
abbau animationen wollen ich will mich
übrigens freuen ich sag das jetzt mal
mittendrin im video weil mir das jetzt
schon wieder auffällig wird wieder
richtig viel dran bearbeiten müssen es
ist gerade 12 uhr ich muss morgen um 9
uhr der uni sein und muss das ganze
video noch bearbeiten und ich sitze an
seiner bearbeitung von so einem video
nun mal immer so circa 12 stunden weil
das auch recht viel ist ich möchte jetzt
hier ehrlich gesagt ich rüber springen
gleich zwei gold habe und er kann
leitermann
ganz ruhig bruder ganz ruhig weg den ich
mir du bist schon mal hin dahinten denkt
auch der könnte mit mir anlegen weil ich
kann da nicht einfach ihm da tut will
dieses spiel gar nicht zu ende bringen
ich fühle mich richtig peinlich
wahrscheinlich wird es kommen auch immer
echt viele leute an nach vorne weg spiel
kein pvp du kannst es nicht aber 90
prozent sagen echt das ist witzig weil
du das nicht kannst also macht bitte
weiter mit pvp also ich weiss man nie
wenn es euch gefällt wirklich dann zeigt
es mir mit einer bewertung weil ich
sitze ich weiß es jetzt schon ich sitze
wieder jahre an diesen an diesem video
hier und habe jetzt gerade eine eisen
spitze geholt das ist natürlich sehr
sehr geil jetzt noch ein paar blöcke
aber einfach nur damit ihr mit zeigt ein
bisschen haye kommt nach reiter
oderstädter in der scheiße weil du
kannst es nicht weil man sehr sehr viele
blöcke die nehme ich mir alle und jetzt
laufe ich in die mitte aber keiner der
mitte ist das wäre sehr sehr premium in
cannes einem interessanten toyota sieht
mir nicht der der sieht mini tatsache
die sie sehen mich die sehen mich
schnell rüber zu blau
er ist hinter mir schnell rüber zu
bleib' ich hab ne eisen spitzhacke ich
kann alles regeln
schießlich am lenin in denen schnell
hoch stelle hoch was was los ich hab das
bett von blau abgebaut jetzt der noch
jedoch getötet
oh mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott
ich habe das bett von blau abgebaut
leute was geht eine krasse wende hier im
kampf jetzt kommt der mann mit pfeil und
bogen habt deren fett abgebaut oder
müssen nur quasi überlaufen und die rund
100 mio das hätte ich nie gedacht was
für eine wende
wir waren ja richtig am arsch hat
überhaupt schon mal mit mir geschrieben
irgendwie ne ne dass man immer noch
immer durch komma sie muss nur
überlaufen irgendwie und musste nur
einmal runter boxen dann sind wir durch
dann haben wir das ding gewonnen alter
wir müssen nichts machen
wir müssen die nur töten die können
ruhig rüberkommen wir müssen die noten
und dann ist alles chillig alter ich
habe richtig angst dass mir diese
aufnahme erzählen die verloren geht weil
ich überhaupt kein bock habe das so was
wieder nicht gezeigt wird die auf
youtube mit mir ich hatte schon mal so
eine aufnahme betrieb ist
dann hab ich das noch geregelt ich bin
einfach überglücklich versteckte
weggelaufen
das ding noch nicht gewonnen vielleicht
töten die jetzt uns auch noch aber ich
habe jetzt mein schwert und dann soll
laufen bruder hier ist man macht jetzt
mal packen tüchern am start da kommt
einer da kommt einer da kommt einer
jetzt hole ich mir immer schwer sondern
dann wird er aber sehr leg dich nicht
mit zohan ich dich nicht mit luca neuer
stehen auch eben eine spitzhacke anstatt
holen und noch ein paar bröckchen die
sind aber auch kinder die haben das
richtig schlecht eingebaut und jetzt
jetzt geht's ab freuen
jetzt wird sich über gebaut wenn er
bogen hat an der mauer widersteht bogen
jetzt könnten die der ordner oder war
toll camp nou
ich muss mich war das alles bedeutet
comics wie derzeit die ganze zeit der
pizza alter
der hatte einfach den weg abgebaut was
ist denn für mappus ja okay ich glaube
ich mit den gleichen weg nehmen aber ich
bin auf jeden fall schon mal ein
bisschen näher ran oder schalter du hier
ist mal eine treppe jetzt hoch das kann
doch nicht sein wie die ich diese spiele
schmiede in die länge ziehen was will er
machen alter wir hatten pfeil und bogen
das ist doch scheiße jetzt deckt er sich
da einfach hoch sind schwachsinn was
will er überhaupt opel ja mal scheiße
jetzt ohne mist zum aufnehmen ist sowas
echt aller unterste schublade das ist
richtig kacke die sollen sie einfach
damit zufrieden geben dass mit von denen
es abgebaut denn so rüberkommt töten wir
die und wenn dann das urteil wurde vom
erst möglich
hauptsache ich predige noch so acht
kommen der soll jetzt ein paar geben mal
tötet die den einfach meine kumpanen
junge was geht denn ich bin einfach ihre
seiten bitten
recht und jetzt weil sie nicht wie du
kommst jetzt hilfe
das einzige was sie gemacht hat
das einzige ist sie stand hinten und die
hat die ganze zeit gefahren ich hab die
kein mal vorne sein zumal sie nach vorne
gelaufen ist es wieder zurückgelaufen
aber jetzt hat sich die ganze die besten
sachen holen um mich jetzt hier
verrotten zu lassen dass sich der spiel
die goethe
ich bin guter klo und akku 25 oder
kuwait theorie süchtig ich gucke jeden
tag mehrere folgen davon einfach richtig
pro tag war noch tot
was soll ich denn jetzt hier machen ich
kann mich ja cool ich bringe mich jetzt
um mehr
ich bin dort echt kurz davor dieses game
jetzt einfach zu verlassen weil ich hier
so dass ich weiß nicht was jetzt noch
bringen soll ich laufe jetzt darüber und
sterben wahrscheinlich habe wieder an
die spitze vergessen oder ist noch ein
gold noch eingerollt noch ein gott und
ich mache mir ein bogen bruder aber auch
die wege ausgepackt guckt euch das mal
an was ihre york attackiert sagt auch
nicht dass der da hinten nur am campen
ist der pizza was ist denn los mit dem
bild das man jetzt schild da hinten sein
leben einfach dass jupp dpa
das frage ich mich immer wie kann
nämlich hier treffen ich will doch die
am arsch der welt männer junge
das ist eher ärmlich man koma ist ab
lauda ist der blödeste blaue ich habe
ihn nicht haben ich hab ihn ich habe
gewonnen
ich guck mal bei mir in der runde super
special ops ist sondern ein cooler
redaktion skin ich liebe ja immer diese
pokemons christina gemacht werden aber
damit befinden wir uns schon im zweiten
spiel ich habe mich wieder total
verhindern und ich bin welche bin ich
wohl schreckt die kommentare die band im
chat rendite unter dem image und alle
die noch mein bruder und mein bruder und
geht ruhig da drauf und macht ruhig hier
und beim und putz und der kripo in den
renntag erfahren ich habe jetzt noch
kein leben verloren als einziger mit
diesem ich hoffe ich übersteuern ich
wenn ich hier die ganze zeit so rum
alter was wollen die denn von mir am
bruder das geht mit dir was will der was
will dieser creeper von mir kann ja mal
auf andere leute gehen anstatt auf uhr
das gilt generell dass skills lab die
skills am starken gastgeber ich schwöre
da kommt wieder auf mich direkt in einen
kleinen umweg und da kommt mein uhr
pascal beim und trifft der vergangenheit
tot
so macht man nein nein
ja ich bin dem anderen immer sport das
hat schon fast wieder vergessen ich
hatte schon fast vergessen umzuschalten
schaltung entscheidung dass ich bin in
stuttgart nachricht
erstmal bet awards gewonnen jetzt hier
gerade zweiter diesen machu picchu krieg
auch noch irgendwie unter erstmal dahin
was soll das hier ist er unsichtbar
was ist los was ist das ist das viel ist
er unsichtbar
was soll das sind dass hacker was sollte
das ist es was sollte wie was soll das
wieso steht der enorm und macht nichts
eine ahnung wie das funktioniert aber
der dahin wenn man zudem hin läuft ist
man einfach am arsch und ich verstehe
das nicht auch ex hacker hits people
ja ich weiß das ist mir auch schon
aufgefallen jetzt nochmal jens kahl
schön auf den drauf und es schon wieder
tot
berlin jetzt erst mal raus und danach
kämpfe ich gegen ihn also ich frage mich
halt immer was bringt es dir werden du
erst drei von ihnen erzählen etwa
zeitgleich runter egal dass ein cooler
mitspieler so weit wenn man so fährt uns
ein bisschen und so aber sowie lehrer
wenn man so heckt und so weiß man nie
was davon halten soll
und jetzt hier nochmal image anstatt
dass ich erst mal wieder image bin und
er sich mit dem da hinten umfasst
und jetzt habe ich bin ich wieder auf
mein image gegangen und ich bin image
das ist klar das ist sehr sehr geil
immer der kamera sterben alter denkt
jetzt ich bin im image oder was denkt er
jetzt gar nicht
leider doch ein leben es kann auch nicht
sein die muss es doch jetzt auch
gewinnen das wäre das erste mal dass ich
zwei mini games gewonnen haben doch
jetzt kommen auch jetzt echt treffen
auch nicht mehr nett ich treffe ihn
einfach nicht mehr um mein gott ist das
ganz spannend ist das gespann icann
youtube das online kommen jetzt stirb
ich habe anderthalb herzen
ok hat richtig weh nicht leben sonst
wird er nicht abhauen
nein nein nein nein aber waren richtig
starkes spiel muss echt sagen das war
blöd dass ich wirklich einmal an diesem
aber nichts mehr ich kenne zwar die blöd
er sich einmal an diesem blöden image
als hannah gestorben
aber es war richtig geil alter dass der
endkampf fand ich echt richtig gut
ihr ahnt es nicht ich bin da drin warte
die ganze zeit und jetzt ist es auf
einmal in game und ich bin einfach
rausgeflogen egal
das ist ja sehr schön scheiße ich wieder
auf mein flex und zu kalt war diese
halten
ich find das war nicht so cool ich muss
euch sagen ich bin halten sie doch als
echtes kurz seiten sieht es gibt aber
dieses blog hier kann eigentlich schon
ganz gut mithalten oder die haben halt
so wenig maps na die haben zwei maps und
die sind beide gleich aus ich glaube ich
nehme den spyder ich finde es vorbei da
immer noch am besten das so einfach
sagen kann hänge ich mich den oder den
oder ich merke ja oder nein oder spinnen
ich bin ich bin ich bin besteht das
versteht es besteht besteht genau das
ist auch hier angezeigt ich bin ein ofen
ich nehme aber mal das bin ich jetzt ich
bin jetzt eine feder also ein münchen
ich such mal als hühnchen ist ein
bisschen 17
die agenda kommen
es war sehr sehr knapp war ich glaube
wenn ich hier und und damit dieses
münchen verrät mich noch das guckt mich
die ganze zeit schon so böse erledigt
vergraben du dich auch noch nein geht
weg nein nie verraten mädchen lasst mich
in ruhe ich habe übrigens diese
spinnweben gefixed aber die sind jetzt
irgendwie noch beschissener ist okay
gibt dem kleinen tätig macht b-team
feuerwehr dieser kuchen hat sich bewegt
ich glaube wenn ich mich als kuchen
verstecken würde würde ich nichts
wirklich wirklich irgendwie überall
verstecken aber nicht bei den fahrten
junge geber weg ihr alter der schalter
wo sind denn mal ein paar high der hand
hat es gibt zwei hunter es gibt nur zwei
hand hat mir noch keiner gefunden
hallo oma bin vielleicht der mann
geschossen aber ich glaub ihr wisst ihr
worauf niemand kommt einfach bei den
haltern verstecken einfach jesu hin
rennen
der guckt denn schon auf dem boot von
den hunter kompletter hier einfach ein
bisschen hofft auch junge das ist echt
also war diese map packs sind echt
teilweise wer guckt hiernach so nach dem
motto natürlich kannst du dir so gut
verstecken fall muss ich schon zugeben
die spinnweben sehen scheiße auch essay
das wäre ja sooo geil gewesen ich hab
die bedford runde gewonnen was nicht
gerade schwer ist weil ich auch ein
gutes team hat also eine person aber es
war schon gut das das gemacht hat so ein
bisschen ich muss echt sagen wow spielt
ihn mit gedacht weil ich bin ich gut im
pvp aber also ein bisschen ich
verbessere mich da aber ich habe auf
jeden fall gewonnen
das ist fakt und die zweite runde wenn
ich dir geworden hätte alter der hatte
ein halbes herz hätte den einmal treffen
müssen dann mehr ich dann eher die ich
gewonnen so visser ist richtig traurig
wenn ich das auch gewandelt und diese
runde bin ich auch locker dann hätte ich
jedes mini game gewonnen
das wäre das erste mal in triple gewesen
dass ich alle drei sachen gewinne
breno player groove first blood wo jetzt
kommt die gleichen hand herum sondern
schaue was er sagt wenn ihr oben münchen
sitzt alter vielleicht bemerkte michael
römhild kommt er überhaupt raus die
kommenden browser ich vollidiot dann
warte ich mal einfach hier vorne drauf
und schaue ob guck mal da hinten denn
die es gibt doch nur noch zwei hand hält
das spiel einfach direkt verlassen du
könntest ja auch einfach ein theoretisch
bei dieser messe schaden ich schade
ich will weiter ich wollte etwas sagen
man kann auch einfach außerhalb von der
mep schwimmen kann man nicht kann man
nicht kann man nicht ich will doch schon
so fasst weil ich bin doch zurück
geschwommen
dabei wird hat der mit dem tier sich
wasserschaden
die haben doch ich geb die da ich gebe
den gleichen wasserschaden ich dachte es
wird erich geier runde jetzt habe ich
einfach nur eine gewonnen
das ist ja richtig scheiße also ich sehe
es hier so als gewonnen an dass ich halt
im gewinnerteam bin also ich kann
natürlich noch gewinnen wenn ich jetzt
hier irgendwie ein bisschen einfach
gewinne als hand an die hühner hier
irgendwie es kann doch nicht sein
kuppelte droht jetzt muenchen nee ich
nehme jetzt den kuchen nicht um den
kuchen nehmt ihr das wünschen kommt bei
kontrakte jetzt hier nochmal direkt in
münchen aufgedeckt die jungs ich wollte
sagen jetzt läuft aber das haben gemacht
gut freunde wenn euch diese folge
minecraft opel gefallen hat dann zeigt
es mir doch bitte mit einer bewertung
weil ich wieder extrem lange daran dass
patienten zu bearbeiten ich habe jetzt
gar keine lust das ganze zu bearbeiten
viertel nach zwölf und morgen rooney und
wenn ihr mehr wollt schreibt es mir und
wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
typisch